[Music]
this is truly this year a category that
is filled with
mastery of the art of cinema when i'm
writing
our script
i never think about anything else but
the story that i'm going to tell them
important to put a kid at the center not
because it was a kid's story because but
because they depend on the understanding
where they landed they always find
happiness in little things and they
always are the answer to or the hope to
humanity i thought it was an opportunity
to to be able to speak about this the
violence that happens in these towns
through the point of view of a child
the movie talks about identity
and talks about the ancestors and
descendants basically i sort of immerse
myself in a reality in a world and what
actually ends up in the script are the
things that i extract from that world
that i'm living the essence of film is
always
universal it's always about emotions
that actually
it's easier to describe them with the
film with the language of cinema